the countries around the world are
reporting shortages of protective
equipment - like face masks not only for
medical staff and but also for ordinary
people but one country that's avoided
this is Taiwan so how do they do it
and could their approach be emulated by
others UW's Phoebe Kong reports from
Taipei
this handmade facemask cover can be
washed and reused for a day or two amid
shortages like for so many others here
face masks have become a necessity in
Josie's everyday life the virus will
spread through droplets I have to take a
path to my office every day so it's more
than one hour that I to share the same
space who is more than 30 people it made
me feel phone safety without wearing a
mask while getting a mosque can be no
easy task in many parts of the world
it's another story here in Taiwan to
ensure the safety of its population of
23 million Taiwan imposed an export ban
on surgical masks as early as January
the government then began rationing
masks to 3 per person per week and soon
after made them available online now
Jersey can place an order for face masks
with an app purchase history is recorded
by her national health insurance card so
that it can be verified before sales for
those who don't want to order online
software developer Kyung Finn John has
developed a real-time mask map to track
face mask stocks in pharmacies people
can check their availability before
heading out this is among the dozens of
online tools that have mushroomed on the
island during the epidemic an exhibition
of public-private partnership and mutual
trust it's not difficult to create such
a map but the key to the successful
rationing system is that the government
is willing to share its data with us
Taiwan's well-established health care
system is our advantage the data of over
six thousand pharmacies across the
country has already been connected to
the official database its enormous ly
beneficial once the data is open to
society panic can be eased as a result
by collaborating with other programmers
across East Asia his map was also
adapted into a Korean version to solve a
similar problem facing South Korea 10
days after placing the order Jozy picks
up her surgical masks at a convenience
store a sacred time people came by mass
in a really fair price you can buy three
masks for less than one euro and this is
really cheap and it's like the social
equality for us you can achieve like the
health is a right for everyone and you
can have them masks to protect yourself
and that is invaluable in these
difficult times taiwan's health care
system and the apps that serve it not
only helped provide masks but
much-needed comfort and stability that
report was the file by DWS that Phoebe
Kong who joins me now from Taiwan's
capital Taipei welcomed a Phoebe and is
their government advice there about the
wearing of masks or is this something
that people have just done for
themselves
well recently Taiwan government has
ramped up the mask-wearing policies
because there is some rep research of
imported cases on the island the island
has now reported over 300 infections
confirmed cases now so the government is
now requiring the citizens to wear a
mask while they're saying indoors and
taking public transport and this can be
done because a steady supply of the mask
can be a guarantee on the island that
Taiwan can now manufacture 10 million
masks a day on his wrong and not only
Taiwan can cater to its domestic demand
but also Taiwan is now trying to help
other countries in other parts of the
world and the government just announced
yesterday that they will donate 10
million masks to the most needed
countries including the US and Europe
and 7 million of masks will go to the
Europe to help medical workers over
there and three masks for less than a
euro seems like a very good price and
were there instances of people trying to
profit here from this situation
now it like didn't happen in Taiwan
because Taiwan government has imposed
strangers measures on controlling the
price of the masks from the very
beginning after outbreak that there's a
most recent merchants are not allowed to
sell masks or to boost this price
otherwise they would be fined or
prosecuted and so this is one of the
vigorous measures that the government is
trying to a stabilizer price of the mask
this is because this is the most needed
supplies during a pandemic and shortly
afterwards all masks our medical
products essentially managed by the
government so our government is
monitoring the whole production line of
the mask from manufacturing distribution
to selves is under monitor and
surveillance of the government so simply
there is no free market of masks in
Taiwan right now and Taiwan has been
praised for its early action in this
pandemic just talk us briefly through
what authorities did
the most difficult of the most critical
measures of to control the pandemic he
said our Taiwan has imposed very early
border control like back in January
Taiwan has cut off drastically cut off
the flight between mainland China and
Taiwan and also to impose a travel
restrictions to certain type of people
so right now I'm all foreign visitors
with our resident certificates are now
banned from entry and the government is
also restricting the overseas travel of
certain essential personnel including
medics and military so they are not
allowed to travel overseas and also
students and teachers are from high
schools and below they're not allowed to
leave the country right now so this is a
measure in a bid to cope with the
pandemic could talk you to thank you for
that if we become in Taipei